I saw a photograph of you in a butt suit
and I want to ask you about it there you
are I keep this photo in my wallet yeah
what's going on yeah nothing that's what
I look like in Spanx I well I think that
this is the year of the ass and my whole
season of the TV show this year where I
was like I just said that the marketing
me I was like this is the year the ass
all of a sudden after the anaconda Nicki
Minaj music video and Iggy Azalea people
are like getting on board with the ass
and you know black guys have always had
our back and been into ass but now all
of a sudden white guys like me are like
ass and you're saying you're saying
they're right they're getting on board
too it's too late for them I used up to
lie I'd be like oh this isn't my only
Kawachi it for a friend
but yeah this whole season of our TV
show is dedicated to the year of the ass
yeah I like the white guys it's like
I've heard of this ass I think I'd like
to try it yes I've grown bored of
[Laughter]
you